Time dilation is one of the inherent qualities in relativity.
That where you have gravitation there's a warp in time
that your time relative to a frame of reference
(to another place where you have less of
a gravitational attraction or less mass)
that time is going to be moving more slowly.
Well that seems like the basis for
some sort of time management.
That you could use gravity to manage time
by way of time dilation where
where you had more gravity and
where others had less gravity
your time would be moving more slowly
relative to them.
And so I decided that I would try to market this.
And I did so by creating time ingots.
It seemed logical enough. I founded a company
called Spacetime Industries.
And these "time ingots" were as you can see...
well, they were bars of lead that i bought on eBay.
And I packaged them though, and...
The thing about this technology is that
you could very conveniently
put one of these on your desk.
And you would have as your frame of reference
ever-so-slight an advantage
over the person in the next cubicle. So...
Granted we're talking about a very very small advantage.
But then I realized there were many other ways
in which to use this sort of advantage
that came courtesy of gravity and of Mr. Einstein.
Namely you could have what I came to call
The Time Warp Undershirt.
A Time Warp Undershirt puts greater density,
more mass, around your heart relative
to the rest of your body. Especially your brain.
And as a result you end up with this
very slight advantage of living just that little bit longer
relative to how long you think you're living.
Or you get to think a little bit faster
relative to how long you're living.
I will grant you that this is a minimal effect.
We're talking about perhaps a billionth
of a billionth of maybe a billionth of a second
over the course of the entire length of
time that the universe has been here.
So you really need in order to be able to feel this
and to take advantage of this in a serious way
you need... well you need a neutron star.
So that's what I came up with
as a way to move forward in this technology.
Namely I came up with a sort of an
architecture that could be built on neutron stars.
What I called an Elevator House.
And the concept of the Elevator House is basically that
every room was on a shaft.
And you could arrange your life by the way
that you arranged the rooms
on these different shafts.
So as to be able to fully manage your time.
And of course up on the roof is the garden
where plants are growing relatively quickly
compared to your life.
And you're able therefore to have strawberries,
as many as you want whenever you want them.
But this is all still sort of selfish. And
still sort of not fully managing time
to the full potential i don't believe.
I think that where it gets interesting
is where it gets communal.
That is to say not to manage time just for yourself,
but what if an entire community had time management
in this relativistic way?
Well, I decided to design some cities
I decided to go into urban planning. Why not?
I'm an experimental philosopher after all.
And so what I did was I designed a few cities.
Now for my cities what i did was i used
the equivalence of velocity to mass
because it was easier at least it was
easier to make some blueprints.
And so i ended up with cities like this.
The cities have different districts that are spinning
very very fast but at different rates
relative to each other
those of you who know clockmaking
are able probably to figure out that
what's going on right here
is that the residential district is
spinning at a rate that is going to give you
a relatively long life span
compared to... those are trees. That's
the agricultural district on the other side.
So you can eat well.
And in the middle is the industrial district which
frankly we do need our iPhones
and other plastic things. But not too many of them.
So it seemed like it really belongs
in the middle. And so I then went ahead and
then I came up with some other cities
that could also be built
along these lines. And submitted these out into the
world. Totally open source.
For any government that wished to take it on
and to build one of these.
Nobody has done it yet
I have to tell you. But it is also interesting to me
that it got quite a lot of attention.
That for instance Architizer
one of the architectural trade publications
wrote it up. And not only them but
also The Wall Street Journal.
And this is interesting to me.
I mean not only is it a excuse for me to boast.
It also is interesting from the standpoint
of what i was talking about earlier.
Namely how to do philosophy in public in a way that
engages people in a broad conversation.
Where what it's about kind of
comes out of the conversation itself.
And so that you end up with, in the case
of a project like this, all sorts of
things falling out of it.
All sorts of ideas that I certainly
didn't have going into it. And
I probably ended up stealing from other people
as I was having conversations with them.
But really in terms of how we think about time
in our society, and the way in which
the arrangement of time
and the understanding of time in communal terms
fundamentally changes time as experienced
and how society can be built
in ways perhaps not using quite
the same amount of elaborate clockwork as I've done.
But in ways that might be truer
to the relationship that we have through time.